die brutale attacke auf oliver pocher
beim boxkampf von felix sturm jetzt
antwortet oliver pocher in einem knapp
14 minütigen statement auf seinem
instagram kanal es ist die erste
öffentliche reaktion von ihm seit der
brutalen tat des rappers und internet
komikers oma der auch als fett comedy
mehr oder weniger bekannt ist ich finde
da noch mal so einen boxkampf erst dann
geht ja darum dass die leute in riehen
boxen aber nicht vorne geschlagen werden
punkt 1.2 ist es irgendwie reiche nicht
wenn man noch nie zum frieden cert für
die ukraine da ist relativ komisch denn
irgendwie bin ich noch nie in meinem
leben gesehen habe irgendwas über
irgendwie irgendwann anders gesagt habe
hinkommt und mit voller absicht ihr eine
lange und es war natürlich eine nummer
die so gar nicht geht dies zeige die ist
hinterhältig dies arglistig die ist
gefilmt die ist noch mit mehrfacher
hinsicht hätte auch anders ausgehen
können ich habe jetzt ein tage auch
ehrlich gesagt damit verbracht das ein
anderer mal beim arzt zu sein und ich
finde auch gar nicht der comedy aspekt
ein bisschen auf achtung hört auf
wortspiel denn man muss auch ziemlich
angeschlagen gewesen und
wenn ich pech habe habe ich ihre parade
schäden die nicht wieder zurückgehen ich
muss montagen der behandlung machen wir
versuchen das einigermaßen wieder in den
griff zu bekommen aber ich kann momentan
gewisse frequenz trägt frequenzbereiche
einfach nicht hören für so eine kleine
backpfeife für was auch immer und der
junge mann hat mir angeboten via bild
zeitung dass er gerne mal ein gespräch
mit ihm führen würde dieses gespräch
wird es geben das freue ich mich schon
sehr drauf
und dieses gespräch mit einem tisch
stattfinden und diese typischen bisschen
länger und dann sogar noch leute dabei
die sich das ganz genau an werden weil
das ist staatsanwaltschaft und richter
und dann wollen wir mal sehen was da
passiert man kann doch nicht einfach
sagen das ist irgendwie okay ist man
kann die sagen wenn ihr jemand nicht
gefällt dann kann der geschlagen werden
dann kann man den behandelnden welt so
funktioniert diese welt nicht ich kann
niemanden ohrfeigen niemanden und was
ich hier mache ist schon und das sind
sachen und inhalte die ich auch begründe
und die kann man gut kann man schlecht
finden aber es hat nichts mit karma zu
tun oder irgendwas dergleichen das hat
einfach mit einsamen tätern zu tun die
einfach nicht ganz sauber im kopf sind
und es werden wir vor gericht und mit
allen mitteln in der nächsten zeit
klären und ich hoffe auf eine maximale
strafe aber trotzdem ich komme da raus
aus der nummer ich werde auch weiter
auftreten ich halt auch weiter sachen
sagen die manche leute unangenehm oder
nicht so lustig finde ich hoffe einfach
keine irreparablen hörschaden und noch
mehr durch diese eine aktion zur hand
einfach saudumm
unlustig war und einfach auch für jeden
der das geklatscht und auf
weiterverbreitet der ist genauso
mittäter und es soll ich cool oder
richtig aber es wird eine teure
veranstaltung werden und da würde ich
jetzt auch die nächsten wochen monate
und jahre darauf hinarbeiten dass wir
hier in residence verschaffen in diesem
sinne freundlichen rechnung schreiben
auch seine frau amirpur hatte auf ihrem
instagram kanal ihre meinung zu der
fiesen attacke veröffentlicht
schlaflos und ja ich habe mich sehr
geärgert
arbeitslose halbstark haben möchtegern
rapper comedian ich weiß nicht was er
gerne wäre
meine man eine backpfeife verpasst aber
eine ordentliche und diese mobbing und
dieses niedermachen leute das sind alles
menschen die sich wehren können und ein
mensch der eine meinung hat aber sowas
mit gewalt zu bekämpfen und dann noch zu
feiern schämen müsse die euch wirklich
also das ist eine doppelmoral
sondergleichen so was er noch ab zu
feiern und zu applaudieren wirklich
gratuliere
nach bild-informationen ist oli pocher
erneut bei seinem arzt gewesen bleibt zu
hoffen dass es nicht zu irreparablen
schäden im ohr des moderators kommen
wird die brutale attacke gegen oliver
pocher jetzt ein fall für die justiz